The main goal of most movies is to tell a
great story that emotionally impacts the audience
in some way.
Viewers know what they’re watching isn’t
“real,” but if the filmmakers do their
job, it will feel that way.
One way of knowing that a narrative has connected
with moviegoers is if people cry during a
specific scene.
Throughout history, there is no shortage of
movies that can start up the waterworks, and
that’s what this video is all about.
Here are 10 famous movie scenes that will
make anyone cry.
Up
Not every film can come out of the gates like
this.
The opening segment of Pixar’s Up chronicles
the love between Carl and Ellie, as the two
childhood friends grow to become a happily
married couple dreaming of seeing the world
together.
As they get older, Ellie unfortunately dies
of an undisclosed illness, leaving Carl feeling
lonely and extremely sad.
Nobody expected what was sold as a fun adventure
movie to start with this sequence, and the
results ripped our hearts right out.
The beautiful musical score by Michael Giacchino
helps the scene resonate even more, and the
tears were out in full force.
The Lion King
Disney has a history of emotionally devastating
the audience, and The Lion King is no exception.
The scene that gets viewers all the time is
Mufasa’s death scene, with Simba trying
to wake his father up following the wildebeest
stampede.
Few things are as heartbreaking as a child
telling his dead parent “You gotta get up,”
before realizing the tragedy of what has happened.
Main characters dying have been a part of
films for years, and at times it’s necessary
to propel the plot forward, but it doesn’t
make scenes like this any easier to watch.
The Lord of the Rings: The Return of the King
After embarking on a journey across Middle
earth with Frodo and Sam, audiences became
very attached to the two friends and enjoyed
seeing them together.
This is why it absolutely wrecked viewers
when at the end of Return of the King, Frodo
says farewell to his beloved companion and
sails off to the land of the elves with Gandalf.
The Hobbits had been through so much together
in their quest; it was impossible to imagine
one without the other.
After all, Frodo wouldn’t have made it that
far without Sam.
More than a decade later, this scene still
makes fans cry.
Knowing it’s coming doesn’t make it any
better.
Toy Story 3
The Toy Story trilogy had plenty of emotional
moments, but few can match up to the whammies
served up in Toy Story 3.
For those who grew up with the franchise,
watching Andy’s toys all hold hands in the
incinerator thinking they’re about to die
is brutal, but the movie’s end had a whole
other thing coming.
Before he drives off to college, Andy makes
a stop at Bonnie’s to give the young girl
his collection of toys, providing each one
with an individual introduction.
By the time he gets to Woody and Buzz, it’s
more than a little dusty in the theater as
the young adults bid adieu to their childhoods.
E.T.
– The Extra Terrestrial
Steven Spielberg films are built on a sense
of heart, which is why the director has been
a fan-favorite for decades.
One of his most popular films remains E.T.
– The Extra Terrestrial, in large part because
of the bond formed between Elliot and E.T.
The two helped each other in several ways,
and that made their goodbye all the more emotional.
All of the kids in the movie had a tough time
seeing their friend go, but Elliot’s is
the most impactful.
Just thinking about E.T. saying, “I’ll
be right here” is enough to make anyone
tear up.
It’s a good thing that proposed sequel never
got off the ground.
I Am Legend
A surefire way to get an emotional response
out of the audience is to hurt or kill an
animal, and I Am Legend served up a doozy.
Dr. Robert Nevelle’s lone companion in an
abandoned New York is his German shepherd
Sam, who keeps him sane and is a loyal friend.
So when Sam got attacked by some infected
dogs, viewers had to bear themselves for the
inevitable.
Noticing that his pet is going to transform
into a bloodthirsty monster, Nevelle has no
choice but to mercifully take Sam’s life.
The pain on Will Smith’s face accurately
reflects how we feel watching this scene.
Saving Private Ryan
The brotherhood between soldiers in the military
is strong, and the team shown in this modern
classic certainly feels like a family by the
end of it.
Tom Hanks’ John Miller was the glue that
kept it together, always doing the right thing
and keeping his focus on the mission at hand.
During the final battle when Miller met his
end, it certainly struck a chord, and even
the most-hardened men got choked up.
He yearned to go back home, and now he’ll
never get that chance.
If that wasn’t enough, the time jump showing
James Ryan as an elderly man asking his wife
if he’s led a good life is all we need to
weep.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
Who says movie tears have to always be sad?
The return of Star Wars was a monumental occasion,
and fans got misty-eyed just from watching
the trailers for Episode 7.
The scene that reduced most to giddy fanboys
was when Han Solo and Chewbacca made their
way on the Millennium Falcon for the first
time since 1983.
With Han proclaiming, “Chewie, we’re home,”
millions of viewers cheered and got swept
up in the moment.
No matter how many times a Star Wars fan sees
this, they’re always overcome with joy and
cry out of happiness.
Few could have predicted an Episode 7 would
ever happen, which made this sweet and unbelievable.
Terminator 2: Judgment Day
At the emotional core of James Cameron’s
sequel is a touching father/son dynamic between
the T-800 and young John Connor.
As the cyborg protects the future savior of
humanity, they form a bond that pays off in
unexpected ways.
After the T-1000 is defeated, the T-800 has
to sacrifice himself so no traces of Skynet
are left in the present day.
Despite John’s pleas, there’s no other
way and the Terminator has to be terminated.
As the robot gets lowered into the steel,
we’re right there with John, crying our
eyes out.
The well-timed thumb’s up is a nice touch
to cap it all off.
Who says cyborgs don’t have a heart?
Good Will Hunting
This drama focuses on the dynamic between
the troubled Will Hunting and his therapist
Sean, who tries to help him overcome his past
traumas.
After many sessions of opening up and be honest
with each other, their time comes to a close
with an emotional look at Will’s file.
Revealing that he too was the victim of physical
abuse from his father, Sean repeatedly tells
Will that none of the bad things that have
happened are his fault.
That one line over and over again becomes
Will’s big breakthrough, as he’s able
to release his pain and move on with his life.
For viewers, this is a satisfying conclusion
to Will’s arc.
Those are just some of the scenes that can
get moviegoers reaching for the tissues.
Which ones did we miss?
Sound off in the comments section below and
don’t forget to subscribe for more fun videos.
Thanks for watching!